in the past year as the pandemic has
dragged on
and on and on we all had to
adapt you know for example a lot of
people were finding new ways to keep
busy
in fact a lot of people were trying new
hobbies
in the last 12 months i myself
am once again trying another awesome
new hobby that i'm very excited to share
it's conan's new hobby
[Music]
see
check it out i just started collecting
quarters
i'm going to try to get all 50 states
now so far i don't know if you can tell
right here
but i have rhode island north carolina
okay that's two two on my way to all 50
states isn't that cool andy
not really what do you mean this is my
new hobby
it's a sweet quarter collection yeah but
i mean it's not really a collection you
just have
two quarters that's 50 cents at this
point and it's
kind of underwhelming yeah it's
underwhelming
because our stupid graphics department
created that
high-energy opening and i told them not
to
yeah it it just ends up making me feel
sad
i'm sorry
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait check
it out
just found another quarter to add to the
collection
conan that's a nickel golf andy
you